with all of this news an actual story
relating to the hunters being added to
the game recently I'd like to go back
and review all of the encounters we've
had with them through both the division
one and two to see if we're any closer
to being able to determine who they are
what role they have played and what
their purpose will be in the coming days
[Music]
we first meet up with the hunters in
Survival game mode in the division one
earlier on in the story
agents are stranded in the middle of
Manhattan during a snowstorm after their
helicopter crashes
they have no gear or supplies and due to
injury from the accident there is
suffering from sepsis which will kill
them within the hour if they are unable
to escape
regardless the agents have a mission to
recover a set of experimental antivirals
and extract via helicopter
however if they make it that far and
manage to fire off the flare gun a new
Elite type of enemy appears and their
objective at this point is pretty clear
to stop us from getting away
but the reasons for doing so aren't so
obvious
all we know about them is that they are
covered in agent watches wear a mask and
fight unlike anything else we have
encountered up until that point with
tech that seems to supersede our own
it was unclear whether the antiviral
said anything to do with it as they
would still attack even if the antivirus
hadn't been found
following this as expected the
speculation started flowing
the hunters are loyal to Aaron Keener
former first wave agents Russians the
third wave and so on but there really
wasn't much to work with so anyone's
guess was just as viable as the next
following survival possibly due to their
popularity we saw the hunters play their
part in a number of other areas
in 1.8 the division 1's last major
update the agents had a chance of
encountering them in the underground
where they could randomly spawn Mid
Mission as well as the resistance game
mode where they could appear alongside
other enemies at certain waves
that would also appear at the end of
legendary difficulty missions
but all of these additions really did
seem to lean more on their popularity
among players than actually being a part
of the mysterious story
even now with that little bit more
information we've received recently
these encounters appear more based on
gameplay than story Focus
truth be told it could be exactly the
same with their appearance in survival
at least at this stage
when the division 2 was released players
were quick to discover that there were a
number of hunters that could be spawned
after following various actions on the
map and when I say quick I mean much
faster than was intended by the
Developers
I think a lot of them were figured out
during the beta
but these were more of a puzzle and an
Easter egg at this stage a way to
collect masks
however over time agents started
noticing them popping up around the map
usually from a distance but not in a
hostile way
in fact if you're able to get close
there would usually just disappear
it's like
they were watching us
the first official story recognition the
hunters were given was quite early on in
The Division II in a side mission called
Agent Edward's support
it had been a while since I played
through it so I created a new character
just so I could run through it again and
make sure I hadn't missed anything it's
at a demolition sight where a half
destroyed Block office was briefly used
by the hyenas agent Edwards was
investigating the area he is requested
backup which is why our agent is
traveling in to meet him there before
making it to the site we are pinged by
many seeing then an agent called Andrew
Edwards is requesting assistance inside
a control point
the building is eerily quiet but there
is an shd request signal alert
hitting deeper into the building the
beating starts to speed up and the
communication signal with many is
starting to break up Suddenly the lights
shut off then almost immediately turn
back on now with some spotlights in the
center office pointed up towards a body
that is hanging from the ceiling
however before the agent can investigate
there is a familiar sound that comes
from the back of the room followed by an
EMP effect that renders shd Tech useless
for a few seconds
ahead of the agents appears a hostile
enemy labeled simply as unknown
but based on the icon and the way it
moves this is obviously a hunter
the agent puts up a good fight but is
vastly underpowered and outmatched
but rather than finishing off the agent
the hunter instead places the agent into
a shock status effect and just struts
around the room for a couple of seconds
before Vanishing shortly after
the hunter had its chance to finish the
job but instead chose to taunt almost
like it was trying to Edge us on
and then leaves
after he's gone contact with many has
suddenly re-established Edwards has been
dead for a while and it didn't sound
like his last moments were particularly
Pleasant given the way he has been found
it is safe to assume he has been
tortured
interesting that his daughter's status
is unconfirmed but given that she is
still listed as a dependent I don't
think that this is significant
what is more interesting here is that he
was supposedly tortured and eventually
killed by this Hunter who would
eventually fight us but leave us alive
it could be speculated that it wasn't
this hunter that killed him but given
that the hyenas have long since left the
building and he hasn't been dead for
long it's more than likely that he or
she was the reason for Edward's Death
so why did this Hunter refrain from
killing us
was this a test
this does pair up with a number of
reports around hunters in DC that are
simply watching us patiently from afar
but then why was Edwards executed what's
different about us
the next time we would officially hear
anything regarding the hunters would be
following the Warlords of New York DLC
during the season three Manhunt where we
are hunting down Baden Schaefer
a hunter would appear when fighting each
Target it wasn't just fighting us but
also the enemy Target we were chasing
down
the same Hunter would eventually turn up
during the final Target Barton Schaefer
but fortunately we were able to take it
down before it managed to get to
Schaefer
though it would appear that it was
actually working with Schaefer
Biden would survive this encounter
barely and be captured by the shd
through the feylau comms it was
discovered that this Hunter had been
organized by Natalya and McManus to help
and then dispose of issues the issues
being the Rogue agents that Faye had
organized to work under Schaefer and
then eventually Schaefer himself after
he began questioning Natalya
the hunter was a cleanup crew for this
particular Manhunt a Manhunt consisting
of Rogue agents that were helping the
Black Tusk agents that were put in place
by feylau who was working under her own
agenda
hidden Alliance reveals and confirms the
cooperation between Natalia Sokolova and
Kelvin McManus
McManus turns out to be the Secretary of
Homeland Security and he has his own
personal unit of covert special
operatives known to us as the hunters
being Homeland Security McManus is not
only aware of the shd from its very
early days but is somewhat responsible
for them
after one of his Hunters was killed by
division agents on Coney Island who was
chasing down Schaefer he is looking to
recruit
Natalia provides him with a list of
individuals under her control that he
could choose from
these all consisted of former division
agents
apart from one Jack Bonnie and this was
the one that McManus decided to run with
in the final Target Mission of hidden
Alliance we end up teaming up with the
target himself true Sun officer
Frederick Lewis
he warns us of someone called the
recruiter and appears to be far better
informed on what's going on than we are
throughout the mission we hear of Jack
Bonnie the latest Hunter recruit being
put through a test with the hunter
appearing from time to time just
watching and assessing
long story short we kill Bonnie so it
wouldn't be all that unreasonable to
assume he has now failed his test
but the hunter recruiter he doesn't do
much about it
he just continues to watch us and then
eventually disappears
that is unless you were like this one
Reddit user who managed to get killed by
the Hunter
I tried to replicate this myself albeit
on a lower difficulty than the previous
time I ran it to try and speed up the
process
it wasn't easy to do and was obviously
not the intended way of playing the
mission but once successfully killed by
the recruiter the following death screen
popped up
Jang Zia
I'm not going to go into too much depth
here as I could spend the next hour
talking about this character in Chinese
mythology
but he's an important figure in Chinese
history he assisted in overthrowing the
Shang Dynasty and establishing the Joel
Dynasty in 1046 BC
Joel was the longest Dynasty in Chinese
history which set the feudalism the
rights and music culture their
Confucianism highly appreciated
and was the period where the most
Chinese philosophical schools were well
developed
while I believe this name to be more of
an interesting Easter egg much like a
number of the Exotic and named weapon
captions we see out there there is a
certain amount of familiarity behind the
history of Zhang xia and what McManus
and Natalia are trying to achieve
to overthrow the current government and
create something better at least in
their own eyes
I'm not going to name the individual but
a writer I respect once said and I'm
paraphrasing here a villain needs to
feel justified in their actions no one
thinks they're evil but sometimes what
brings people Joy is problematic and
dangerous
so a name like this Zhang xia being
given to a character like the recruiter
just further shows the belief the heaven
what they're doing
the overthrowing of an evil misled
government to instate a new world order
so with this recap there are a few
questions I have and this doesn't just
involve the hunters but the story itself
however to be fair the hunters at this
stage seem to becoming a major part of
the story now
how many of the missing first wave
agents became Hunters if any at all we
know a lot of them joined with Kina dyed
at his hands or died in the aftermath of
the virus being released
but there are numerous more that haven't
been accounted for
does this have anything to do with what
Kino was telling us about for all this
time with us having no idea what was
coming and as the rogue agent Network
and Anna have anything to do with it
Alice's Memoirs mentioned something
called the button which is a common term
referring to the nuclear football
emergency Satchel or the black box
this is a briefcase of which the
contents are to be used by the president
of the United States to authorize a
nuclear attack
how does this involve McManus and the
hunters the fact that Alice mentions
Natalya and McManus in relation to it
implies that there is more to come
regarding it
at this stage I'm really hanging on to
the fact that McManus chose not to
recruit one of the Rogue agents that
Natale offered to him and was more
willing to give the younger less
experienced Jack Bonnie ago I don't
think it's that he doesn't have former
agents in his ranks but that he's had a
few issues with them in the past and has
now chosen to keep them separate from
the hunter program
it could even be that this is what Kina
was talking about
perhaps he was approached and as he
learned more about what they were doing
this is when he really went off the
rails
he could see what was coming he started
recruiting for his cause and setting up
his own Isaac Network known as Anna that
could work outside of McManus and the
shd's control
Kina may have initially parted ways with
the division because he was left behind
in the dark Zone when the government
pulled out the jtf but now I believe
there is more to the story
Kina learned of McManus Natalya the
president and the button
he took it upon himself to fight back
against something that the division have
no hope in stopping with the current
structure
particularly with McManus being somewhat
at the helm
there have been a lot of questions
regarding the way Kina went out the way
he suddenly became the classic comic
book super villain with a plan to
release his new and improved supervirus
on the city of New York
what if this wasn't what it looked like
from the outside
what if this was more about targeting
McManus Natalya and all the hunters or
maybe a way of bringing them all to one
location Liberty Island where they could
be dealt with isolated from the rest of
the city
Kina was never meant to survive that
encounter and he seemed quite
comfortable with that
however I don't think he ever intended
on firing his virus into the city with
the intention of wiping out civilians
or maybe it wasn't meant to leave
Liberty Island at all
but I don't think that any of what we
saw was intended for us either
regardless he uses it as an opportunity
to show us Isaac's flaws
I think we ruined his plans on that
island but not in the way we think we
did
even if he did end up releasing the
virus into the city this was collateral
damage he was willing to take especially
when considering the potential nuclear
fallout that McManus and Italia could be
planning on causing
anyway long story short I believe Kina
was approached a long time ago and
because he's been such a huge Thorn at
menace's side he has chosen not to
repeat that mistake and avoid shd agents
altogether
so why then are the hunters watching us
well firstly they haven't been ordered
to take us out yet
secondly they aren't mindless drones
these are highly trained and experienced
special force operatives they still
think for themselves and while they take
their orders from McManus right now
maybe it won't always be this way
it certainly wouldn't be the first
faction in the division to split away
from command
we the player agent are the strongest
and most resilient agent they've come
across screw you Kelso it's true so
perhaps they see something here maybe
they are watching all agents they come
across like Edwards but depending on how
they react they are choosing to execute
those they deem unworthy
I think they see something in us and
their leader the recruiter won't allow
them to take us out
or maybe this has nothing to do with
Kino at all
maybe he was just that unhinged former
agent we saw at the end who was
attempting to fire a supervirus missile
into the city perhaps the button doesn't
just refer to the use of nuclear weapons
it could be talking about using
biological weapons something similar to
what Keen was planning on using or maybe
even a way of mass spreading a cure
what better way to show you the best
option for the future of the country
than by providing a cure to the problem
that started it all
on the organizational chart of the U.S
federal government the Strategic
Homeland division is formally listed as
part of the Department of Homeland
Security
however the division reports directly to
and only to the president of the United
States
but in saying that the non-classified
elements of directive 51 specify that in
the event of a catastrophic emergency
all governmental power will be
transferred to the president top
advisors and a committee including the
vice president National Security adviser
National continuity coordinator the
assistant to the prison for Homeland
Security and counterterrorism and
finally the continuity policy
Coordination Committee chaired by a
senior director from the Homeland
Security Council staff
so the president and the vice president
now did as well as various other members
of the presidential Advisory Board it
makes sense that McManus now sees
himself as the new director in charge of
the shd
but all of this started before he had
much control of them so he's been
preparing and establishing his own
counter Force for the shd agents a unit
even more secretive in nature than the
division themselves
while the hunters have been used as
somewhat of a cleanup crew for not just
Rogue agents but the shd in general this
doesn't appear to be their main
objective
are they simply mcmanus's praetorian
guard while he worked through the
details of obtaining power of the US
government
were they distant for much more in the
coming days
yes he has control over Natalya and the
Black Tusk but these are just the force
that make up the numbers of his wider
Army the hunters are his unit loyal only
to him
at least for now
obviously there is a huge part of the
story that is still to be revealed some
of it sitting with Barton Schaefer who
still isn't woken from the coma we put
him in but also more still to be
revealed by McManus himself
for now we're as close as we've ever
been to learning the origin and identity
of the hunters
but as far as the future role goes only
time will tell
this has been my recap of the Hunter's
faction as a whole from the early days
of the division one up until where we
are now halfway through year four of the
division two
it goes without saying that we'll hear
more about them in the future but for
now this is all we have to work with
given what we've more recently learned
about them what do you think the future
story holds for the hunters let me know
in the comments anyway thank you very
much for watching and I'll catch in the
next one
cheers
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]